I am in Greenwich and I'm standing on
the Prime Meridian zero degrees of
longitude this foot is in the eastern
hemisphere that foot is in the Western
except my GPS tells me that I'm actually
about 100 meters west of the meridian
it's actually a little way over there
and that's not an accuracy problem the
reading is correct so what's going on
well first of all the earth it is shaped
like a a slightly squashed sphere but
that's an approximation in reality it is
not a perfect sphere or I'm not just
talking mountains and valleys here the
entire thing is a little bit lumpy so if
you're designing a latitude and
longitude system you cannot take into
account all those lumps instead you pick
a mathematical perfect spheroid one that
is as close as you can reasonably get
now the audence survey the wonderfully
named british government department that
deals with maps shows they're spheroid
in 1936 based on earlier survey by
Victorian astronomer Royal George Airy
all official British government maps to
this day use that spheroid as their base
and it works brilliantly incredibly well
for the UK why the measurements were
taken unfortunately the world is lumpy
and Aries measurements weren't quite as
good for the rest of the globe so over
the years dozens of other spheroids have
been chosen around the world each one
fitting best to a particular country but
no one minded that for a very long time
because the resulting maps were never
used together they were on paper so any
map that was accurate enough that the
spheroid could make a real difference
would only cover a tiny area of the
world
and besides you navigated using local
landmarks you never had a magic device
that said here are some numbers you are
here but then the space race came along
and suddenly we have satellites and we
have the need for one standardized last
using longitude for the world so you
knew your missiles were going to hit the
right target so in the 50s over at Johns
Hopkins University in the US the Applied
Physics Laboratory and the US Navy set
up the first satellite navigation system
and as the base point that their
calculations they used there last year
and longitude that venue based on their
North American spheroid now that's fair
I then changed many times over the years
the scientific world refined its
calculations but that baseline stuck for
American systems
you probably see where this is going the
GPS system an American military
invention that's now a global standard
uses a descendant of the American
spheroid and baseline the Royal
Observatory up on that hill continues to
use the British spheroid because while
our government uses that spheroid
because it's more accurate for
Geographic calculations within Britain
but also because it would be incredibly
inconvenient to move that hill
a hundred meters that way who's right
both of them neither of them
the truth is there can be no actual zero
Meridian first rule because the earth is
lumpy it's always going to be a little
bit wrong but also because the Earth's
tectonic plates move according to GPS
Greenwich is moving and so is pretty
much every other point on land modern
latitude and longitude are a
mathematical abstraction nothing more so
I really am in both hemispheres at once
it just depends how you measure it